[MUSIC PLAYING]
BEN BREEN: Hello.
Thanks, everybody, for
coming along to what
is otherwise a cloud
conference to hear a little bit
about Android.
Do you all hear me
OK, first of all?
Great, cool.
So yeah, today
we're going to learn
a little bit about
Android Enterprise
and what's coming up.
My name is Ben Breen.
I actually lead Android
Enterprise engineering,
and we're actually
based out of London.
Android is actually built
between two locations.
We have the largest team
here in Mountain View,
but we also have a team
of around 300 people
in London as well.
So this session,
we're going to see
some of the new things
that are coming up
in the next release of Android.
And I have to say
this disclaimer
that some of the things
you see here today,
they may not make
it into the release.
I think they will, but there's
always a chance that they
don't.
So yeah, this is why
Enterprise is important to us.
In 2019, Android
is forecast to ship
over 280 million smartphones
intended for business use.
And according to
research from IDC,
in 2018 81% of personally
owned smartphones shipped
for businesses will
be running Android,
and 67% of company-owned
smartphones
will be running Android as well.
So I'm not showing these numbers
simply for vanity metrics.
I'm just showing
you them to show you
how important
Enterprise is to Android
and why we are investing
so much time and efforts
into our B2B initiatives.
So there's been sustained
investments in Enterprise
across multiple
releases of Android.
In Lollipop, we introduced
something called the work
profile for BYOD,
which allows users
to completely separate work
and personal in their phones.
In Marshmallow, we
introduced the concept
of corporate-owned,
single-use devices
and runtime permissions.
In "nugget", so as we say in the
UK, or Nougat, as you say here,
we introduced the work
app security challenge.
So getting into
certain apps, you
might require extra
authentication
such as a fingerprint
or pin code.
And we also introduced
the digital well
being aspects for work profile,
allowing you to turn on and off
the work aspect of your phone.
And in Oreo we added
zero touch enrollment,
which means that as soon as you
take your phone out of the box,
it enrolls itself
into your organization
without the need for
any contact with IT.
And in Pie, we introduced
multi-user improvements,
ephemeral users, users that
only use the device occasionally
or as a one off, and further
improvements to work profile.
And we'll take a
look here at what
we're going to introduce
in Android Q as well.
Now, most of Android
Q will be revealed
at Google I/O, which is
another conference that happens
in around one month's time.
And so definitely
follow that as well,
because you'll get all
sorts of announcements
around some of the
Enterprise and also
non-Enterprise
aspects of Android Q.
So the Enterprise team focuses
itself on three types of user--
IT admins, ensuring that they
can easily manage and secure
Android devices and to minimize
the number of support tickets
that come through;
line of business,
so specialists, in-house
applications or specialist
hardware; employees,
ensuring that employees
are able to control their
privacy and digital well-being.
And also, we're
ensuring that Android
is the most productive
platform for employees to use.
Android also provides
multiple layers of security.
So not only is it
a robust platform
built from the ground up to
be uncompromisingly secure,
Android also supports dedicated
security hardware, such
that you might find in
Pixel and many other phones.
Android has management
APIs to allow
EMMs to enforce policies
and give IT visibility
into the security
posture of the device.
And also there is
Google Play Protect,
which allows always
on app analysis
and takes automatic actions
should anything untoward
be happening on the device.
So if we look at security
through the eyes of Gartner's
mobile OS security
reports, Android actually
leads the way with security.
It's the most feature complete
in terms of built in security
and also corporate-managed
security.
On here, light blue means weak
and dark blue means strong.
And we pride ourself
in being secure.
And on my team, we have a
number of Enterprise security
specialists complementing
the platform-wide security
specialists we have as well.
So I think one of the big
misconceptions about Android
is that it's not
a secure platform.
In fact Android security
is robust and effective,
offering Enterprise
grade protections
and controls to ensure
devices are secure.
And in fact, in Android
8, there are more areas
which are rated stronger
than any of the competition,
according to Gartner's
reports in 2017.
So that includes app
updates, secure browsing,
authentication methods, device
wipe and corporate wipe,
workplace isolation, and
app monitoring and control.
And actually, the 2019
report is due out shortly,
and so we'll see where Android
9 features on that as well.
So Android is also
easy to deploy.
We offer a wide range of
methods to setup devices.
QR codes and NFC bumper
are really popular now,
particularly on
dedicated devices.
And in Android Oreo, we
introduced zero touch
enrollments, which I
mentioned before, and is now
very popular as well.
And it's something you can speak
to your mobile carrier about,
and they can set
this up for you.
And then on the device
management side,
we provide multiple modes
for IT admins to choose from.
For personally
enabled devices, we
offer something called the
work profile, which I'll
introduce on the next slide.
So these devices are
typically referred to as BYOD.
Work profile offers
a unique approach
that protects work apps
and data whilst respecting
the privacy of users.
And for company-owned devices
we offer three options.
One of them is personally
enabled devices.
So we offer a work profile
for company devices
as well, which offers users
a separate segment where
they can not only
operate in a secure way,
but also have their
privacy respected as well.
We also have a
work-managed mode.
And for single-use
devices, we also
have COSU mode, where you can
lock the device to certain apps
for certain use cases.
So this is work profile.
This is one of my favorite
features of Android.
And the way that I often
explain this is it's
like having two
phones in one phone.
On the left, you've
got personal.
On the right you've got work.
And actually, you can simply
turn off your work phone
when it's time
not to be working.
So there's a switch
at the bottom.
And there's also an
OS-enforced security boundary
between the two, which means
that IT can manage and do
whatever they want
in the work profile,
but at the same time, whatever
happens in the personal profile
is private to the user.
And you can still ask
those device-wide questions
like is there anything untoward
happening on the device
and take action accordingly
without compromising
the privacy of the user.
So it eliminates those
scenarios where people might
be carrying around two phones.
And also we've seen
one of the main reasons
for the lack of adoption
on BYOD as being people
are very conscious
about their own privacy.
So this is a way where
people can maintain
that privacy on a single phone
And so some of the
benefits of work profile.
It offers a great
work/life balance
it allows people to
turn off work when
it's time not to be working.
But it also allows
IT to make sure
that the device
is secure as well,
and they can manage the
work side of the phone.
Another feature that we have in
Android is managed Google Play.
So this is a part
of the Play Store
which you can curate and
control as IT admins.
And you can also silently
push out apps as well.
And if you have a
work profile, then
on the work profile side when
you go to the Play Store,
you will go to the corporate
part of the Google Play,
and if you're on a
personal profile,
then you'll access
personal Google Play.
And you can also remotely
configure applications,
such as setting proxy
servers for Chrome
and all of that type of stuff.
Another thing we've been
working on really hard in 2018
is making sure that IT and
users have greater consistency
across Android.
So one of the callouts that
we've had when we speak to IT
and users is the
devices can be quite
different from an
Enterprise context
depending on which
device you pick.
And it could be quite
confusing sometimes
to know which device
to choose to buy.
And so with all of
these device options,
we decided to try to help
standardize around some best
practices in the industry.
And so we launched Android
Enterprise Recommended
for mobile phones.
And this was really
about helping
IT admins to make
informed selection
decisions around the phones
that they are buying.
So they know if a phone is
Android Enterprise Recommended,
then it supports a very rich set
of features for the enterprise.
And it also has a high
degree of standardization
when it comes to
things like UIs.
Secondly, we also wanted to make
sure that all of these devices
supported zero touch enrollment.
And we also wanted to make
sure that all AR devices have
regular and frequent security
patches applied to them
as well.
So by choosing an Android
Enterprise Recommended device,
you can be confident
that the device is
going to work well in your
enterprise, and consistently.
So, so far on the knowledge
worker side of devices,
we have 12 OEMs onboarded
with this program
and over 60 devices.
And for rugged devices we have
eight OEMs and 15 devices.
So our main focus in 2018
was launching this program.
And our focus now is raising
awareness of this program
and making sure that
IT are aware and have
a large set of devices with
consistent capabilities
to choose from.
And this year, we've also
launched AER for EMMs.
So an EMM, sometimes
it's referred-- sometimes
people refer to them as UEMs.
So these are your MobileIrons
or AirWatches or Google endpoint
management are the things
used to control and monitor
your fleet of devices.
AER for EMMs ensure that
EMMs support Android
in the best possible way.
And when we launch new
features for Android,
they are available sooner
for you to use via your EMM.
So we have a number
of EMMs already
onboarded to this program,
as you can see here.
And we'll be expanding
the AER program
to include mobile
carriers and system
integrators later this year.
The other focus for us
is line of business.
So line of business.
We're talking about specialist
devices and specialist
apps, often built in-house
for your business.
And often when we think
about Android Enterprise,
we think about more
traditional use cases
for smartphones and tablets.
These devices are driving
end user productivity
and are used for customer
service, back office,
and support.
But where Android really shines
is for all the other device
types and use cases.
We see single-use devices
deployed in the field
and set with
service technicians.
Customers are using
Android for rugged tablets
in harsh environments.
And in retail and
hospitality, customers
are deploying Android devices
as kiosks or points of sale
systems and digital signage.
And we're starting to
see exciting use cases
for AR and VR here as well.
And because of this
device diversity,
we're able to serve the needs
of a wide range of industries
from field service to retail,
hospitality to health care.
And because Android
is an open platform,
we, at Google, don't
need to be experts
in each of these industries.
OEM partners are able to
develop highly specialized
devices to meet these needs.
And the other exciting
part of device diversity
is we now have mobile devices
reaching far more people
than before.
So turning front-line
workers into--
front-line workers,
warehouse workers,
field service technicians,
all into knowledge workers.
And we also have
a robust platform
for building experiences.
So we provide a large variety
of the leading developer tools
to create line of
business applications.
So you have Android
Studio, and obviously,
you can build in Kotlin, Java,
C++, and other languages.
One of the things that
I've been learning recently
is Flutter and Dart.
So I tend to work on
OS, so I don't usually
use high-level
programming languages.
But I think Flutter is really
interesting because it's
for the first time, I
think, one of the tool kits
that allow you to genuinely
write code once and have
it run with the
native experience
across multiple OSes.
So you can use Flutter
to create iOS and Android
apps with a single code base.
We're using it a lot
internally inside Google now.
And you may have seen we also
announced Hummingbird recently,
which is an
extension to Flutter.
I think it's in alpha.
But it also allows those same
apps to run on the web as well.
Prior to this back
in my long history,
I did stuff in Qt for
cross platform development
and then I did some
stuff in Xamarin.
They all had their
pros and cons,
but I've been really
excited about Flutter.
And under it as well, you
have machine learning--
TensorFlow Lite, and ML
Kit, so on-device ML.
And you have Google Play for
distribution and third party
development tools such
as SAP and Salesforce.
And, of course,
developers can integrate
with assistance, on-device,
or Cloud Machine Learning.
We have a few use
cases in Google
where we do learning on device.
But we've also
got some use cases
where we do the
learning in the cloud,
but then apply the
knowledge tree to the device
and use the ML software
on device there.
AR and VR is--
Augmented Reality,
Virtual Reality
is becoming increasingly
important with a lot
of business customers and
Android things as well.
And of course, Android apps are
natively supported on Chrome OS
as well.
So thinking about
employees, well, of course
you've got your familiar
productivity apps.
And the employer
can only see what
happens on these badged apps,
the ones with the briefcase
in work profile, if you
have a work profile enabled,
which means that if you're
not using a badged app,
you know that you have the
privacy that you expect.
And, of course,
you've got turn off
work mode on your work profile,
which I introduced earlier.
So what's next?
What can we expect in Q from
an Enterprise perspective?
Well-- key themes, improved
end user experience,
more IT control, and
enhanced security tools.
So corporate-owned
devices can now
be enrolled through zero
touch, QR code, or NFC
directly into work profile
during setup wizard.
So that was previously
not possible.
Now if you have a
work profile enabled,
then you can enroll users
directly into work profile.
This is not for BYOD devices.
This is for
corporate-owned devices,
again, giving your
users that separation
between work and personal.
Another request that
we had was on a device
with a work and
personal profile,
if I'm trying to
schedule something,
I need to see where
I have a free slot.
And I need to see both
my calendars together.
And so that's something
that you couldn't do before.
Now we've introduced an API,
which if your IT admin allows,
some calendar information can
flow between the two profiles
and can help you
find where you have
a free slot in your calendar.
And if you want to edit
something in your work calendar
from your personal
profile, you can do that.
What actually happens is the
work version of the app comes
to the foreground .
It looks like you're
within the same app.
You're actually not.
It's actually switching
between the two calendar apps--
from the personal to the work--
and allowing you to edit the
details of any calendar item.
So, it keeps it secure
Another popular request
was separate input methods
for work and personal apps.
So obviously, IT
have strong interest
to make sure that
there aren't things
like key loggers installed or
apps which might be sending
information onto another server,
whatever people are typing in.
Well, now you can say,
for my personal apps
I want to use this keyboard
while still maintaining IT
controls for the
work apps as well,
so supports having two
different input methods.
And also more IT control.
Going forward, you'll be able
to install updates manually
from a file.
This allows users to test
rollouts, stage them or stagger
them, and prevent bad
bandwidth or scheduling issues.
So you can actually
make sure that phones
are getting updated when
people are typically
offline or asleep.
And that builds on what we
added in Android 9, which
is the ability to freeze device
updates for up to 90 days.
We've also improved
Wi-Fi provisioning.
So IT admins can now
configure certificate
based Wi-Fi networks
during setup
and put those credentials
in a QR code or NFC tag.
And this simplifies setup and
makes connectivity automatic.
Now I think I
anticipate a question on
is it safe to put those
credentials into the QR code?
I think it's going to be using
the easy connect standard,
if you're familiar with that.
But I think security
shouldn't be a concern.
But let's see when the
final version comes out.
So we also support
device certificates.
It was only a
short video anyway.
It's not a huge problem.
So we also support
device certificates
through Google Identity.
So now what you
can do is connect
to a public Wi-Fi network,
provision the device so put
in your credentials.
And it will automatically
download the certificate
and then connect you to
the Wi-Fi network requiring
the certificate.
I will say simplifying
setup as well.
Enhanced security.
So there is a concept of DPCs.
You might not be
familiar with it
unless you're heavily into EMMs.
But a DPC is the app that EMMs--
like your MobileIron, or your
AirWatch, or your Intune--
installs onto your device
to then manage the device.
Now often the EMM is
not an expert in, say,
analyzing network activity and
working out whether something
untoward is happening there.
And so what you can
now do is delegate that
to another app that can
do that analysis for you.
And the same for certificate
installation and installation
of apps.
Another common feature, which
was blocking deployments
of work profile, was
the ability for a user
to install an app
from an unknown source
on their personal profile.
Now, as an
administrator, you will
be able to block the
user from installing apps
from unknown sources on their
personal profile as well.
So you can guarantee
that everything
has come from the Play Store
and has got both the server side
and client side protection.
So that's a feature
you'll be able to turn on
as an administrator.
Another thing we've added is
a screen lock quality check.
So we have this API
before called DA--
Device Admin.
And that's now been deprecated.
One of the things that
did was allow you to--
or allow an app with privileges
to change the pin on a device.
And that was useful for
EMMs and things to make sure
that a strong pin was in place.
But it was also a door for
things like ransomware, which
could just put a new
password on your device
and ask you for money.
So the way we've got around
that is you can now interrogate
the OS to say, does the
password meet certain criteria
for strong?
And if it doesn't, you can
promptly use it to take action.
Or you can take action
yourself to erase the device
or do whatever else you want.
We'll also be adding
private DNS supports
so organizations can
require DNS over TLS
to avoid leaking URL queries and
to keep all those internal host
names secret and secure.
[MUSIC PLAYING]